先生 先生がお休みになる時にお聞きになると今日はなんと人間はつまらない
この間かやぬく会館で出したでしょ
あの  や や ってやつ  CDで出したでしょ
あなたがつけた あれも
うん わかります  餌を求めるという感覚だけじゃなくて
なんかこうやりたくて
例えばボランティア活動とか
いろいろ感情 何かの感情があってボランティア活動をやったりとかっていうのは
これは単に餌ではないんでしょうけども
でもなんかそれをやらんとこう落ち着かんから単にやってるだけっていう場合もありますけども
そういうふうなのは一体どういう風に
それでも徳業になりますよ
商売じゃないんだから
落ち着かんとなんかこれやらなくちゃということでやっても
それによって まあ商売ではないし
それでもって自分が生計立ててるわけでないならばね
善行になります  映画を見たりなんだとかっていうのと微妙にそういうのは次元が違うわけなんですね
うーん まあ映画見たり
それはまあそうでしょうね
映画を見ると自分だけ楽しむんであってね
ボランティアやってると自分の映画見るような感じで楽しむためにやってるかもしれませんだけど
それによって誰かがやっぱり助かってますよ
そこら辺微妙に違うんです
映画を見ると その時間は何かしなくちゃイライラするぞってことをやってるでしょうね
でも自分だけ楽しむんであって
ボランティアやろうと思っちゃうと
やっぱり誰かに助かってるでしょ
もう何て言うか こう 資本主義的な考えから
その仏教的じゃないかもしれませんけど
徳の考え方で こう だから資本主義だったら金があったらそれを儲けさせて
さらに大きな金に変換していかなっていう部分と情熱に囚われてやるんでしょうけども
何て言うか 自分が今何かがあれば
それを徳にどんどん変換していって
少しでもいいことをしようっていう回路になったら
なんかそれは一種の こう
これも何かの取引じゃないんかなと
頭の中でそういう考えがよぎったりするんですけども
それはどう考えればいいんでしょうか
だから資本主義は世界で素晴らしいシステムやと思ってるでしょうし
それだったら まあだったらもっと格好いい資本主義にすればいいんじゃないんですかね
じゃなくて その資本主義はもうそれはもう自分はもうあまり興味がないと
だから時間と金があれば
資本主義だったらさらに金を増やすっていう方向に持っていく回路を
例えばその徳 時間と金があれば
それはもういつ死ぬかわからないから
徳に素早く変換してしまった方が勝ちだという考え方に切り替えたとすれば
要するにそれは言ってみれば
その資本主義だと金でさらに大きな金を取るというふうな考え方で
要するに取引をしているわけですよね
それをだから要するに
金時間を使って徳を取引するような感覚で頭が回転するっていうのは
それはどういうふうに間違っていると考えたら
どこかちょっとおかしいっていう考え方が
おかしいと思うなら どこがおかしいとはっきり言ってほしい
なんかその取引してるみたいなっていうのはいいのかっていうことなんです
だから取引悪いんですかね
取引する場合は一番自分にとっては一番いい条件で取引するでしょうね
資本主義っていうのは
自分にとっては何のいい条件ないのに取引でしょうね
何のために金を使い金を儲けるんですかね
忘れてるでしょうね なんで金が入ったんですかね
これすごい人工的なものでしょうね
人間に金がいらんでしょうね
これ人工的な上で 人工から人工的な思考で資本主義っていうのは本来的な考え方でもなんでもないんです
金消しちゃえば 1 日にして世界から
自然なものじゃないでしょうね
だからちょっとこの約束事のことになったことが
今それが神様になっているでしょうね
メモみたいなもんでしょうに
例えば人がもうかぼちゃ 2つ持ってくる
で 自分がもう半年経ってから自分が米ができますけど
今は何もない それじゃあありがとうということでかぼちゃ食べちゃって
で またあの人に米があげなくちゃいかんって忘れちゃう
それでちょっとメモを書いておくと
ぐらいのことでしょうに
じゃあ君 これ持っていってくださいと
メモ見て あ 君からかなり半年前でかぼちゃをもらったんだから
じゃあはいどうぞっていうことでしょうね
金っていうのはそんな働きでしょうに
それが何やと今さら そこがもう本来の働きからね
もう逃げてしまって ただの約束の紙でしょ
あれは 書いてますよ お金ってちゃんと
日本のお金読んだことないんですけど
これ持ってる人にはまあこれぐらいはもう払うことを約束します
ちゃんと約束文書を書いてますよ
金に  ノートですからね
うん ちゃんとサインもして
だからこの とにかく我々のお金では
日本ではありますかね
そういう契約は書いてます
これから調べます 日本のお金も書いてるかないかと
アメリカのドルでも書いてますよ
ちゃんと じゃあもう調べましょうか
何か書いてるのかと 契約
質問に答える そういうことは面白いんです
何も約束してないね 危ないな
日本の銀行にお金預けて
例えばこのシンガポールではね
This note is legal tender. これ法律的な紙やと
約束やと  Legal tender fifty dollars 50ドルの legal tender ですと
Chairman Board of Commissioners of Currency Singapore
これに対して chairman が
議長がサインしています
きちんと フーツー フーツーツーという人
やっぱり金っていうのはそういうものなんです
私は結構調べてみると金持ちですよ
アメリカの金もあります
はい  1ドルですけど  This note is legal tender for all debts
借金ですね  Public and private
サインしてるのは Secretary of Treasury
大蔵省のベンセン ライトベンセンともう一人サインしていますよ 2
人がサインしています
だからまあ これは 1ドルだからということではなくて
100ドル札でも同じ文章です
そういうふうに書いてるただの約束のあれでね
これだけ経済の中心に居座るっていうのはちょっとね
どうかなと思いますけど
だから忘れているのは金は何のためかということは
資本主義が忘れているでしょうに
聞いたらへっちゃらな
いろんなくだらんことを言うでしょうしね
金だったら何でも買えるって
なんで何でも買えなくちゃいけないんですかね
何でも買っていいわけないでしょうに
ゾウも買える ライオンも買えると
トラも買えると あるいはウォーシップ
何でしたっけ 戦艦買えると
金が 戦艦買ってどうするんですかね
買えますよ だから何でも買えるという考え方はもう愚か者の考え方でしょうに
何でも買えるんじゃないでしょうに
だから金は必要なものを買うためでしょうね
だったら必要なものを揃ったら黙っていなさい
落ち着けと いうことじゃないんですかね
理性的といえば そこで必要でないものまで買ったりすることで
もう全ての生命に迷惑でしょうに
だから取引するならば
自分に対して一番いい条件で取引すればいいのです
でしたら もう生活を幸せで幸福でいられるお金がもう確保できたら
もう得をする方に行くしかないでしょうね
なんか資本主義の思考と何か似ているよ
だから嫌っていうのはそれは説得になりませんよ
誰かの誰かの話が似ていたんだからって
こちら知ったものじゃないでしょうに
だから人は資本主義を持ってこようが共産主義を持ってようが
仏教に関係ない そんなことは
どうせ人間がやっていることだから
ろくなものじゃないと知っているし
仏教で言っていることは
時たまたま共産主義に似ているかもしれません
資本主義に似ているかもしれません
だからといってそちらと関係ないんです
だからこちらではもう理性のある人間っていうのは
もう取引するならば もう自分にとっては最高の条件で取引するんだよということで
これは最高な条件の取引
自分のどうしても人間に生まれたならば
自分のことは自分でやらなくちゃいけないということで
自分では頑張る 頑張ったところで理性でもっと頑張っちゃうと
結構収入が確保できる
で ちゃんと安心して食べていられる生活できるもの確保したところで
もうそれでは止まりは止まってあかんと
それからさらに取引をしていくんです
その取引が世界の幸せにもなりますし
自分の儲かるためだけやっている仕事はそれほど社会の役に立ちません
どうしても自分に金が必要だから
もう手段選ばずやっちゃうでしょうね
だからいろいろ騙しもあるし
詐欺もあるし なんで品物は 2週間か 30日以内だったらもう返してもいいと話があるんですかね
気に入らなかったら返還できますよと
そういう条件あることでわかるでしょ
売っていることはくだらないと
だから買った客にはいいと思って買ったんだけど
やっぱりこれダメやということになりますからね
売る側はもうそんなことを考える暇がないんだから
とにかく とにかく売りさばく
いらんものを売ったところで
向こうは訴えちゃうとこちら商売上がっちゃいますから
もう 30日以内だったら返してもいいや
あるいは 2週間以内だったら返してもいいやとかね
法律まで作らなくちゃいけない
ですからこの人間は金が必要な場合は手段選ばないんですよ
生活するためにはお金が必要
その時はもうとにかく闇雲にやっちゃうんですよ
泥棒でもするんで 万引きもするんですよ
必要な時は でなきゃ生きていられないんだと
そこは万引きまでしてご飯食べるのはもうアホでしょうに
だったらしっかりと仕事をしてしっかり頑張って
もう自分の収入を得る
そこまでは善行為にはなりません
時々買い物をして もうお客さんに対してもう調べずそれで買わない調子になってくる
ちょっときつい態度取ったりするんですよ
ヤクザみたいに はっきりしてください
買うか買わないかとかね
言うと怯えて はいはい
分かりました 買いますとかね
そんなそこまでやっちゃいますよ
でも正しいわけでもないでしょうに
で それで自分の適量の収入が確保したところでどうするのかと
最も儲かりなさいというのは
それ自体無知な話でしょうに
人をバカにしているでしょうに
生きることは大事でしょうに
だから最も儲かりなさいというのは人間の人権侵害ですよ
それで金を金を生むということで
無限大に金を生むことになっちゃうんです
だからそこで無限大に金をむくだったらどうして自然破壊でしょうに
だって自分がお腹が空いている場合は泥棒でもするんだから
悪いことするでしょうに
同じことを続くでしょ
その場合はとにかく金を作らなくちゃいけない
最も金儲けはなくちゃいけないというと
また手段選ばず無限大に金儲かることになる
それ自体すごい恐ろしいシステムなんです
そうなってくると だから世の中で犯罪は絶えないでしょうに
戦争は消え絶えない 搾取は絶えない
ちっぽけな竹島とかなんとか
それに喧嘩する 私は日本総理だったら爆弾一つ落としちゃう
潰しちゃうんです それ
それよりはお互いに憎しみ合う合わない方がいいんだよと
ケチ 金持ち 金あれでしょ
それも あの島があったらそこら辺の海が取れるんだから
で そういうことはどこまでも進むんじゃなくて
自分個人の収入が確保されたところでさらに頑張りますが
そこでもプラスアルファになることをやってみると
悪いことじゃなくて 人を助けるということになるんです
そういうことによって
いまだに自分の収入確保をいろんな条件でできなかった人も
それで助かるでしょうし
憎しみ合うことは消えるでしょうし
あの人に金があってよかったよかったということになるでしょうに
そういう時 今は金がある人はもう警備で警備員に自分を身を隠して行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
いつでも 見るたびに気持ち悪いがっしりした男ばっかしの間でいなくちゃあかんでしょうに
で 金持ちが人を助けになってくる
その誰一人もなく どこへ行ってもみんなわっと寄ってくるでしょうに
定期でどこでも行かれるでしょうに
だから王様の気分になりますけど
資本主義だったら金持ちっていうのは奴隷で
もう犯罪者の気分で もう警備の中だから我々犯罪のこと同じです
すごい大事に警察に守ってくれるでしょうに
同じことですよ 資本主義で金儲けて犯罪者で生きるか
仏教的な取引あって王様の気分で生きるかという
だからまあなんか似ているんだからといって
それはもう知らん 私は
これが一番利己的な取引なんです
最高な条件で これ以上ない条件の取引なんです
だいぶ時間も押してますが
よろしいでしょうか 質問の方
それでしたら ダンマパダ講義はここで終わりたいと思います
この後 本当は五時半からなんですけど
三十分ほど時間差しに入れまして
六時から瞑想会の方に入りたいと思います
また三十分休憩した後にこちらの方にお集まりください
初心者指導を受けられる方は前の方の席に座ってください
では 参拝で終わりたいと思います
参拝  [背景音]